bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj allora vi spiego
una roba noi in questo momento siamo ad
amsterdam sono anche vestito dalle da
link non fatemi domande su questa roba
perché non mi so dare una risposta
il fatto ragazzi e uno allora noi siamo
venuti qua ad amsterdam e non abbiamo
detto niente email non l'avevano detto
hanno mantenuto il segreto
questo perché ho voluto fare una
sorpresa ad un mio amico che si chiama
nicolas che lo conoscete anche come
nichi box e lui mi ha sempre parlato di
amsterdam insomma lui è molto più fan di
amsterdam che che noi e quindi niente
ragazzi ho voluto fargli questa sorpresa
non dicendogli niente gli ho detto vieni
a milano cinque giorni e slide a me e
poi una volta che è venuto a milano l'ho
portato in aeroporto e poi siamo partiti
per amsterdam pierre è una cosa che
volevo fare da tempo solo che non ho mai
avuto la possibilità e oggi alla fine
anche grazie a quello che faccio che ho
avuto la possibilità di farlo quindi
volevo ringraziare anche voi perché
questo regalo è anche fatto da parte
vostra perché se non ci fosse stati voi
non sarei manco io qua e quindi non
avrei potuto fare neanche questo
sorpresa a nicolas adesso vi faccio
vedere come siamo partiti per amsterdam
quindi anche come nicholas ho scoperto
che saremmo andati ad ansar da noi ci
vediamo alla fine c'è proprio questo
vestito di link buona visione
poiché i ragazzi sono arrivato da nichi
ma che fai sotto le fontane i blog alle
7 del mattino
facciamo la gara a chi blocca di più
vero papà
marco è contento ma che vogliamo
ok ragazzi è arrivato il momento sto per
dire a nichi che andiamo ad amsterdam
perché ormai siamo in aeroporto uno fa
due più due dice ma che cazzo succede
quindi adesso di ronnie che andiamo ad
anzano vediamo che cosa succede ciao
andiamo lì zio di cosa ti darei che
lancia la borsa di tra licola
andiamo al ladro al ladro nuova dunst
abbiamo ad amsterdam si lagnava cinque
giorni dai reati capito perché non
mentre l'inter perda bene un lieto di
annunciarvi che quei big money della
partner mi sono comprato la easyjet e lo
trasforma taini tj tudor al
travestimento giusto per salire su lisi
j
certo non sei così non puoi salire su
suggerimento di stefano aviogei ha
comprato tutto comprato i soldi fatto i
soldi ho fatti tanti vero signore stiamo
salendo per la prima volta sulla mia
compagnia aerea easyjet
ieri sono i migliori li ho fatti proprio
bene come quello di the forest anche
come ho fatto io per tratte dall altra
parte
faccio un saluto ai ragazzi siamo
arrivati al posto di scoperto di avere
vicino alla persona non indifferente per
tutto il male che piace il tuo posto
finestrino il vostro finestrino
ho perso il taxi ciao papà ho perso il
taxi
ok
e poi chi ragas siamo arrivati davanti
alla porta dell'hotel c'è questo e
niente ragazzo è entriamo nella stanza
for the first time la porta è gigantesca
c'è un iphone attaccato fuori perché
fammi vedere quanto film
la madonna quanto sono gnocco non avete
visto che ti portano a giusto il nostro
è cosa è fatto apposta
allora io in genere ogni volta che entrò
nelle stanze devo fare la roba che mi
lancio nel letto al contrario
il fatto è che qua ci sta la spaccatura
in mezzo semi lancio al contrario muoio
ripieni mentre fra succede cosa grazie
mi spacco poi ti regalo la videocamera o
perfetta al pronto
come figo morbido è il pacchetto di
patatine grosso più grosso ma come io
questa roba qua questa cosa non la farei
ma neanche se me lo chiedesse selena
gomez nuda per terra te lo chiedo io
va bene andiamo sarà
mascellani
perché sma c'erano tutti raga io vi
giuro che sta giostra l'abbraccio covo
subito la faccio adesso papa c'è un
ragno gesù cristo c'è il ragno grosso
c'è la mamma più grossa orca la eva
dovunque andiamo poi devono giocare alle
macchinette dove vincono i pupazzi
perché ora che adam sono ancora indietro
queste sono streghe blog con una strega
epico finito male di che si fanno le
lambo coi soldi della partner di youtube
che si fa cioè dalla mia
la mia macchina 300 chilometri all'ora
in 5 secondi ragazzi mettere niente o
reca all'estero i nomi dei ristoranti
italiani non c'è verso non ne fanno un
onore quell'uomo colpaccio sulla testa
per cortesia non fumate mai che poi
diventate così o così lo sa il papa
perché non danno mai soldi ai bambini
olandesi perché perché van persie
jack ragazzi coi big money e ho comprato
anche questo locale di ansia pro è veri
jj e luca ragazzi stiamo andando non
solo le casse mandando però siamo in una
via di amsterdam ci sono le case storte
quindi non è una leggenda quando sei
fumato le vedi che sono al contrario
deve di vera festa della ditta ci sono
gli stivali attaccati ai alle cose delle
lievi dei negozi dove non vendono
stivali c'è sempre tudor che salutiamo
tutti quanti ovviamente la camicia da
boscaiolo che ti conferisce più 30 punti
in falegnameria poi giochiamo stefano
raffreddato siamo tutti la fascia
offrendo porco dimenticato di aggiungere
questa cosa
e adesso stiamo tutti seguendo papa che
sa dove stiamo andando vero papà mamma
gag mag e mike ma vecchie devono
bestemmiare in tutti i titoli dei
ristoranti in tutti i team tutti ho
finalmente ragazzi un ristorante
italiano
niente niente da fare
il sonante santa vergine niente niente a
quanto è quotato il prossimo ristorante
che si chiama madre di dio ma papà ci ha
riportato in giappone ragazzi sono
tornati in giappone tutta la roba
giapponese cioè ma come cosa other fa
cassa caffè vi racconto una cosa che per
voi sarà tanto divertente per me no
c'era papa è un ora e mezza che
continuava a dirmi se andiamo a fare
quella giostra lì che ti diverti e io
continuavo a dire no perché mi pago
addosso badagnano che divertente io no
perché mica go addosso perché è alta ma
vedete che alta al terzo no che ho detto
dopo un po vado su instagram guardolo
stories di martin garrigues
e lo stories di marchi galli è questo
si no
dunque quel [ __ ] era là sopra e io
ho detto no papà ho paura ad andare la
somma non ci vado
quando sono stronzo è colpa loro ma
abbiamo perso martin garri papa sa non
cogliamo raga ma non è che voi ci avete
presente per caso i negozi dove vendono
i fenicotteri
no perché io questa cosa non la sapevo
tutta l'erba di amsterdam se la sta
fumando snoop dogg in questo momento
ragione su caster da adesso andiamo a
rubare lo zucchero filato a step nicosia
caso
ragazzi e nicky box andiamo direttamente
qui ho detto che mi faccio
io ci passò anche camminando dritto
insomma mainichi giocate vai
lo scasso
ho mai
ad andrei a tutto braccio
la chiamo rotta qualcosa vabbè tanto
forse scassata va bene va bene fa niente
che fa
basta ci si può andare avanti una scelta
incredibile se pare lo scivolo o se fare
le scale e noi facciamo via che lo sci
fi bru senza pensarci adesso vado io
grandissimo
va bene ragazzi a distanza di due giorni
hanno deciso incredibilmente di non anzi
di togliere l'aspirapolvere che era di
fuori della nostra stanza bottino però
in compenso hanno lasciato un bambino un
bambino in fasce grazie grazie
siamo tornati adesso tra nicolas vuole
condividere con noi una cosa che ha
visto oggi se tu rubi oggetti da questo
negozio noi
tifi a tifà firmo pagare 150 euro per
ogni oggetto che troveremo non dicutere
basta
spero che vi sia piaciuto cose di un
argomento è un mi piace anche la pagina
facebook e come indotto per la
descrizione 16v chiamano cosimino
ragazzi